Alex here with another gamespot news  update are you still playing The Witcher  3 well then get ready to sink another 30  hours into this massive RPG Conrad to  maskavich which will freeze game  director told game reactor that the to  add ons will introduce about 30 hours of  new content to the game according to the  length of the witcher 2 the first  expansion hearts of stone will span  about 10 hours of gameplay while the  second called blood and wine will offer  about 20 hours of play he said but it's  possible they could end up being even  more substantial he explained the  expansion packs will be whole new story  lines with all the elements you've  gotten the main story like cutscenes new  characters new items new Gwent cards and  many many more parts of stone munches  this fall while blood and wine will  follow in 2016 you can buy them together  for 25 dollars